la casa blanca está tratando de impulsar
la tasa de vacunación en estados unidos
que parece estancada en un 50% de la
población empezó a hablar incluso con
foxnews cadena de noticias que simpatiza
con los republicanos y con las ideas del
expresidente trump de hecho son hannity
un presentador de esta cadena cercana al
ex presidente invitó a su larga
audiencia a confiar en la ciencia y en
la vacuna sin embargo la vacuna sigue
representando una división política
entre republicanos y demócratas esta
semana el senador republicano ron paul
volvió a cuestionar en audiencia pública
el rol del instituto nacional de salud
al financiar un estudio que según el
senador habría contribuido a generar la
pandemia en esta campaña por lograr
vacunar a más estadounidenses twitter
suspendió la cuenta de marjorie tale o
la congresista que simpatiza con la
teoría de conspiración que ganó no por
compartir información sesgada e
infundada sobre la vacuna y el comité